long lines are back at food banks across
the country families overwhelmed by the
rising prices brought on by inflation
how we doing people it is july 18 2022
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
we are live streaming on rumble youtube
and blaze tv subscribe tap the
notification bell you know the story
and we got a big show for you on this
monday i hope you're feeling refreshed
hope you're feeling good it's the middle
of the summer and i hope you're taking
politics with a grain of salt so that
you can enjoy yourself in the middle of
the summer i know that i am which is why
i'm in a good mood on this monday
morning but we got a big show for you
we're going to be talking about those
crazy lefty woke progressive democrats
can you believe it they're all insane
but we're also going to be talking about
their media counterparts we're going to
be talking about the ridiculousness of
this administration
and uh we will talk about some of the
few there are a few people out there who
are doing some good things and fighting
this nonsense and as always we want that
avenue to be open for the people who are
waking up to the nonsense to come to our
side we have cookies we're nicer and
happier and we're freedom loving and let
you live the way you want to live so
that will be the theme for today real
quick let me talk to you about relief
band which it's perfect for today
because are joe biden and the democrats
disastrous policies making you nauseous
did you know that one out of three
americans regularly suffer from nausea
well there's a solution you've got to
check out relief band relief bands the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that's clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with the
bidet administration motion sickness
anxiety migraines hangovers morning
sickness chemotherapy and much more it
works by stimulating a nerve in the
wrist that travels to the part of the
brain that controls nausea then it
blocks the signal your brain is sending
to your stomach telling you that you're
sick it's like the name says it's
legitimately a band that you wear on
your wrist
to relieve from nausea and anxiety and
you change the intensity depending on
how you're feeling to make it stronger
or weaker it's that simple the
technology was developed over 20 years
ago in hospitals to relieve nausea from
patients but now through a relief band
it's available to the masses the
products 100 drug-free non-drowsy and
provides all-natural long-lasting relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed and they just released their new
model relief band sport the sport is
waterproof has extended battery life and
can attach to your apple or android
watch so if you're finally taking that
summer trip or just nauseous from
everything going on in the world i've
got good news right now you can join
over a hundred thousand relief bound
users for an exclusive offer just for
our listeners go to
reliefband.com use promo code ruben and
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and a no questions ask 30 day money back
guarantee that is
reliefband.com and use promo code ruben
for 20 off plus free shipping i'm pretty
sure that joe biden's assistant could
use that right now because things are
not going well okay so let's just dive
right into it there's a lot going on in
the world right now we're going to get
to biden's trip to the middle east a
bunch of
snafus and gaffes and it's basically
been a complete disaster and the media
can't hide it much longer
but one of the interesting things that
is going on right now is that we are
seeing
the awakening of the liberals yes i kind
of did it years ago plenty of people did
it before me including ronald reagan
himself and frank sinatra and many
others but liberals are waking up and
they're waking up real fast because the
woke thing has decimated anything close
to what was a moderate liberalism of
times long gone and now people who would
not really think of themselves as
conservative
are realizing that liberalism is really
banged up and it's not just in the
united states it's uh happening in a
very specific way up in canada so joe
rogan you might have heard of this guy
he has a popular podcast program it's on
the internet somewhere i'm told it's on
the internet a couple people watch him
uh he is waking up pretty freaking fast
you may remember just a week or two ago
he said that he probably would support
ron desantis for president and now he's
going off on justin trudeau and just let
me say before we throw the clip the
reason i showed these things about guys
like rogan and bill maher etc is because
they represent a small sliver of people
that still can be changed this
disaffected liberal this younger person
who factory setting was a liberal who is
now waking up and realizing boy things
aren't exactly what they seem so here is
joe rogan on what's going on up in
canada and their evil whacked out
communist leader justin trudeau
canada's communist candidates they're
[ __ ]
they're [ __ ] they gotta get rid of
that guy how much time does he have i
feel like he's been prime minister for a
while am i wrong i don't know i don't
know how their system works up there i
have zero understanding of their system
yeah i never looked into it at all i
just i didn't even i just liked him i
liked him before trudeau yeah yeah i was
like he's a handsome guy yeah seems
sweet yeah you know it's like good good
looking guy confident good talker yeah
and then during the pandemic i'm like oh
you're a [ __ ] dictator yeah oh you
don't like criticism you're trying to
shut down criticism by saying that all
your critics are misogynists and racists
yeah who said that about the trucking
people the truckers he called them call
them all misogynists and racists
yeah he's gross
he's a sketchy guy yeah and he's got
some [ __ ] shaky deals
i would like to see like where the money
is coming from like why why do you want
everybody to get injected every four
months they don't need that anymore like
what do we do okay so to be clear i am
not showing you that telling you that it
is the most incisive political
commentary ever but it is interesting
that joe rogan and again this guy is the
biggest podcaster it's bigger than the
reuben report it's true uh he is the
biggest podcaster in the world he's
saying hey i don't know much about this
canada guy
this guy up there i don't pay much
americans didn't pay much attention to
canada before all of this lockdown
craziness and you say no the guy has
nice hair and he wears nice suits and he
speaks nicely but what happened which is
what often happens to these liberals
they're not really liberals but these
liberal leaders is they get unmasked the
second you scratch
a liberal a progressive you find a deep
authoritarian and that is exactly what
has happened with justin trudeau it's
exactly what's happened with basically
all of our blue state governors and
mayors etc etc you guys get all that but
he's saying rogan is saying hey i don't
know much about this but i do know a
little something about freedom and this
guy when the truckers were out there and
you guys all remember the canadian
truckers we covered it quite extensively
when these truckers were out there
saying hey we want to just be able to do
our jobs we want to be able to deliver
goods we want to keep the economy going
and you're demanding we get injected
with your experimental vaccine we you're
demanding we get injected with it so
that we can leave the country via plane
uh you're locking us down i mean they
had toronto montreal all over canada
they had some of the most draconian
lockdowns there's still vestiges of it
all over canada they have far more
damage than most western countries and
they don't have the defenses whether it
comes to free speech or your ability to
defend yourself
that we have here in the united states
so this showing this really bleeds into
a broader time where the left is now
losing credibility from sane liberals
right that all of these people you look
at justin trudeau he looks a certain way
he sounds a certain way oh he must be a
good guy turns out not to be a good guy
you look at say gavin newsom in
california he looks a certain way his
suits fit he's got slicked back hair but
then you scratch him a little bit you
find the worst sort of authoritarian
leader we're going to get to dc mayor
muriel bowser in just a second biden the
media et cetera it's like all of these
things are being unmasked right now
we're in an unmasking phase and i think
the challenge for the rest of us that
are just freedom-loving people it's like
how do we take these refugees because
they're they're they're worried right
they're going oh my god can i be a
conservative or a libertarian or just
not a knee-jerk lefty could i be that i
thought those people are all racists and
bigots
it turns out that we're not it's wild
it's weird wild stuff
all right so we're going to get into all
that let me talk about real estate
agents i trust real quick you know
buying or selling a home is already one
of the most stressful things you can do
and it can be 10 times worse if you're
not working with the right agent
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment that's a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously which is exactly
why i recommend real estate agents i
trust they work with only the best
agents in every market they do their
homework talking to every agent before
inviting them to join their network and
here's a big one they only work with
full-time pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents
their team makes the introduction and
then follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go to real estate agents itrust.com
provide them with some basic info
they'll contact you to make an
introduction to an agent in your town
you move and you live happily ever after
pretty sweet so okay speaking
of
lefty leaders that seem nice on the
outside that are pretty boys that have
nice hair that wear suits that fit that
often have fancy socks that have nice
teeth
but beneath all that turn out to be
really horrible people we now have to
talk about california governor gavin
newsom and that means that i have to put
money in this jar because i'm mentioning
california and gavin newsom soulless
extra five today solus gavin newsom the
american psycho of politics someone who
will say and do anything absolutely
anything uh to attain power someone who
as we showed you on friday when joe
biden was out of the country magically
showed up at the white house to meet
with joe biden's wife dr jill biden and
meet with the vice president they are
planning a slow-motion coup joe you just
don't know it well anyway
gavin newsom was in the news not only
because he showed up at the white house
but he did an interesting uh interview
with la television and also he's been
going after ron desantis and and he
dares occasionally say the word freedom
which is a word that should be banned
from his mouth because he does not
believe in freedom at any level
whatsoever well he did an interview a
couple days ago on la tv and uh it turns
out that uh in about a week from now
it's looking like la is bringing back
mask mandates yes what a time warp we
live in
well he was asked about that
la county has moved from medium to high
risk for the spread of the virus the
nation's most populous county is
preparing to bring back an indoor mask
mandate if the covet search continues
this morning here in l.a county the
nation's largest county home to 10
million people we could be two weeks
away from reinstating an indoor mass
mandate here and
l.a county looks like it's about to put
in a mass mandate back
when the rest of the state is not does
that make sense to have certain parts
where you can literally go across the
street you got to wear a mask and and
other places where you don't is that a
good policy at this point in the
pandemic look
um localism is determinative this is a
bottom-up frame the end of the day i
keep reminding people because i keep
reminding myself california is the size
of 21 state populations combined
the conditions up
in northern california near the oregon
border very different than they are in
the southern part of the state and so i
do believe in regional approaches i do
believe in flexibility at the local
level now you see the exact opposite
mandates denying flexibility at the
local level coming out other states
we believe in a different approach so i
think that needs to be tailor-made
through the elective process and the
delivery process at the local level i do
think that's more appropriate
okay i want to be very very clear and
clean with my words here
it is my belief as a free citizen
of the united states of america
that gavin newsom does not have a soul
i think it is possible that he is not a
human being i think perhaps he is some
sort of cylon or alien or per maybe was
created in a lab somewhere
but that is not a human being his
ability to lie
with no
clearly
no thought into what his actions are and
how they differ from his words is
absolutely incredible so he believes in
localism he locked down his entire state
now when they're trying to bring back
mask mandates then he's sort of into it
oh yes they should be able to do it
they're deciding what they do locally
but let's just flash back to a year ago
if a year ago if one of those counties
up near the oregon border had wanted to
not lock down he would have been all
over them so he's a liar the idea that
he cares about bottom up governance is a
complete lie he loves big government he
loves high taxes he loves more power
from him for himself did he believe in
localism when he was dining at french
laundry without a mask with lobbyists
did he then when he was locking
everybody else down
didn't stop him from spending 30
thousand dollars on booze at french
freaking laundry uh i don't know how you
can i've said this before i don't know
how someone
look we can all make mistakes we can all
regret decisions we've made we can all
evolve politically certainly all of
those things are possible he is nothing
other than a high level
fraud
con man everything about him everyone
needs to know it you need to tell all
your friends because he's obviously on
his way to the national scene right now
they are trying to figure out a way when
they get biden out to make him vp and
then maybe they'll push kamala out so
he'll be the the democrat nominee in
2024 so that they can actually
push california policies all over this
country he has demolished california
california in the last two years had
never before the last two years had
never once had a net loss of population
twice in a row last two years 2020 2021
they have lost population these people
are going all over the country to get
away from him and his policies so i just
don't understand how you could say that
i believe in localism no you don't
nothing that you have ever done has
shown that you believe in localism that
you believe in bottom-up framework you
liar
but this is what they do these people
are hypocrites they are bs artists and
it never ends so now we move to another
democrat this is video of democrat mayor
muriel bowser she is the dc mayor big
democrat uh things are not going very
well in dc right now and suddenly she's
very upset at the biden administration
because you're not going to believe
what's happening in her little city
because they keep letting all these
illegal illegals in she's having some
problems the washington post reported
last week that homeless shelters in dc
were filling up
and groups were getting overwhelmed by
these buses that the governors of texas
and and arizona are sending here full of
migrants
how significant is this influx how many
people
well this is a very significant issue we
have for sure called on the federal
government
to work across state lines to prevent
people from really being tricked into
getting on buses
we think they're largely asylum seekers
who are going to final destinations that
are not washington d.c
i worked with the white house to make
sure that fema provided a grant to a
local organization
that is providing services to folks
but i fear that they're being tricked
into nationwide
bus trips when their final destinations
are places all over the united states of
america god these people they're so
ridiculous so first off democrats
basically are for open borders we'll get
to more on that in just a second they
have been tacitly if not
factually welcoming all of these people
we have we have actual numbers on it in
a moment um and now she's suddenly
realizing oh
when they come here it's a problem
because not in my backyard because now
our homeless shelters are being overrun
i love how she says we believe that
they're asylum seekers it doesn't mean
anything it means nothing everyone all
over the world would love to come to the
united states for whatever reason they
might want to come they're an asylum
seeker so she's okay as long as we
disperse these people all over the place
but fortunately we have something called
federalism we have these states rights
and we have competent governors in
places like uh say texas and arizona
which she mentioned and uh florida and
that's what you call that gavin newsom
that's localism people electing their
representatives in their local cities
and states to take care of them so
that's exactly ironically what's
happening here with these red states
they're saying okay you get in here
biden administration isn't going to take
care of the border or you guys are just
going to flood us over what are we going
to do we're going to put them in buses
and send them to d.c and now the
democrat mayor of dc is very upset
because she's okay with open borders
until they show up at her house now we
got a bit of a problem
but you're going dave dave this seems
like a bit much it can't be the joe
biden administration policies that are
causing people to come people that they
know they can't just walk into the
country they know that joe doesn't want
people walking
right into the country that's not how
things work
videotape we had a chance to talk to
some of these migrants from venezuela
and they are thanking president biden
take a listen
he's a good president with so much help
that he's given us it's been very
difficult what's happened to us our trip
has been very hard thank god we're here
we thank you for receiving us and
treating us well
look at that look at all of those tacos
wandering over the border
that's dr jill biden that's not me taco
time and they love
joe biden because he's telling him to
come and that's what the administration
has done so we got some info here
because i know you guys like numbers i
don't want to just throw things at you
without any backup information so rnc
research posted this on twitter uh this
is really fascinating so basically 207
000 illegal immigrants were apprehended
at the border last month that's june the
most apprehensions in dhs history
meanwhile the biden administration
claims that the border is closed so now
before i show you some some other
numbers i'm going to get you some other
numbers in just a sec how that compares
to say years past what's interesting
here is that if you're apprehending 207
000 people that that's good right that
means oh we are protecting the border
now we don't know
this is the key part of this we don't
know actually how many are coming
through but there's plenty of video of
it and now we know in places like dc
when they bust them in they're suddenly
not happy about it so it's hard to track
the illegals who actually come in
because you're not going to believe this
when they walk in they don't go okay i'm
here here there's all my paperwork i'm
here and i'm illegal don't worry about
me i'm going to uh sat you know i'm
going to sheboygan um so here are some
numbers just to give you a little
context of how out of control these
numbers are uh so june of this year it
was 207 000 apprehensions june of last
year 189 thousand now here are the key
ones november of 20 it was 43 000 and
june of 20 it was 33 000. so this has
exploded
the apprehensions have exploded so what
does that mean the messaging from this
administration is has sort of been
basically come here right the messaging
from that crazy orange man's
administration was do not come so then
less people were inclined to come so
there were way less apprehensions and
there were way less people getting
through so even though we don't know the
exact numbers on the illegals coming
through but you guys have all seen the
videos just wandering through the border
and again muriel bowser is very upset in
dc because they're sending her to her
they're sending her to her hometown
we know that the numbers are absolutely
exploding and we can completely uh place
the blame at the doorstep of the
democrats on this right it was not
happening under trump it's one of those
things wasn't happening under trump kind
of like inflation wasn't happening under
trump kind of like gas prices weren't
going bananas under trump kind of like
we didn't have a couple crazy wars under
trump etc etc uh but what else is going
on with this administration how's joe
biden doing how is he mentally and what
was he doing this weekend all good
questions dave thanks dave uh well he
went to the middle east and uh we showed
you video a couple days ago of the
disaster in israel he said he was going
to honor the holocaust he didn't know
where he was going he
shook hands with air et cetera et cetera
well here he is uh getting to saudi
arabia and some of the fist bumping and
other such nonsense but after promising
during the 2020 presidential campaign to
make saudi arabia a pariah for the
murder of washington post journalist
jamal khashoggi the president traded
tough talk for fist bumps urging the
oil-rich nation to boost production amid
rising pressure to combat sky-high
inflation and soaring gas prices the
saudis made no such guarantee during the
trip
okay so to be clear he met with the guy
that he said he wasn't going to meet
with he fist bumped him instead of shook
his hands then he asked them for more
oil even though we have plenty of oil
here if he would just uh say
turn the turn the gasket on that thing
we could have also got the keystone
pipeline going and a whole bunch more
but it gets worse uh he's not doing well
physically
we'll always honor the bravery and
selfishness selflessness of the
sacrifices of the americans who serve
all right that's just another one of
those things he's honoring the
selfishness of those who have served
america
sort of like honoring the holocaust uh
then he had a he had a coughing fit do
we have the coughing fit let's go with
the coughing fit
and uh
i had a terrible
headache excuse me a terrible headache
and uh
i'm sorry
you know it's funny we're all sitting in
the room and we all kind of laughed at
that one when we showed it when we did
our run through before the show and now
look it's sad this is not what how it's
supposed to be this should not be the
president of the united states
i like old people you guys know my
feelings about the golden girls okay
uh
this this whole thing is not how it
should be going down but there's
something like i have a terrible
headache he's coughing he doesn't know
where he is like this is not good and at
some level i guess you just have to
laugh at it which is why we're all
having the same reaction
of how depressing this really is uh but
anyway uh he had said that when he goes
if he goes to saudi arabia first it was
in if then it was a win if he goes to
saudi arabia he was not going to meet
the saudi prince because the saudi
prince did some bad stuff he killed
khashoggi he's not going to meet with
him i think we've got some video
i'm not going to meet with
i'm not going to meet with nbs i'm going
to an international meeting
and he's going to be part of it just
like there were people part of the
discussion today
all right so he's not going to meet with
him
i think we've got some side but
i'm not going to meet with mbs i'm going
to uh i couldn't meet with him prayed a
tough talk for fist bumps
but you're fist bumping the guy you're
not meeting with that was the best
moment of the whole freaking trip
anyway the media is also having a
nervous breakdown because they realize
nobody's listening to their nonsense
anymore they they ran cover
for this guy who is just completely
losing it they know that the democrats
are losing the latino or as they say the
tinx vote and uh
the jig is up the jig is up so now we're
going to show you some video from cnn
cnn used to be a place of journalism
it's a partisan democrat outfit
and here's a guy by the name of don
lamont
and uh he's struggling he's struggling
because
there are bad people out there and and
he's trying to be a journalist
we sit around and we talk about these
things and we want to give this false
equivalence to democrats and republicans
that is not where we are right now
republicans are doing something that is
very
dangerous to our society and we have to
acknowledge that we have to acknowledge
that as americans we must acknowledge
that as journalists
because if we don't we're not doing our
jobs we cannot sit here and pretend like
well you republicans it's a cut them a
break let's we want to hear whatever
they have a lot to answer for in this
moment
a lot to answer for what happened with
the former president of the united
states whether you agree with abortion
rights or not why they have taken back a
right that was what the you know that
was granted to american women for 50
years we have a former member of the
oath keepers who is saying we are in
very dangerous territories
territory we have a history professor
who is telling us right now that the gop
is becoming more and more associated
with extremists in that
guys a history professor doesn't like
the republicans sweet jesus send out
something on the wire a history
professor
a professor at a university who's a
partisan hack who doesn't like
republicans this is incredible this is
absolutely staggering and i'm freaking
out guys
ugh so ridiculous first off let me just
qualify with this i used to be friends
with don he's been on the show he was a
decent guy he really was something
broken trump broke him
black lives matter broke him i don't
know what broke him uh but way back when
actually when i had him on the show he
was openly talking about how uh islamic
violence radical islamic violence
against gay people is a problem i'm
pretty sure he wouldn't talk about that
anymore because he's gone full woke but
he's everything he said there you could
completely do the reverse of and it
would make more sense the republicans
have gone extreme well wait a minute you
mean the democrats have gone extreme
when they locked everybody down and how
in all the democrat-run cities there's
no law and order and lockdowns
all that stuff like any of that
then he's the republicans have to deal
with january 6. oh yes that thing that
riot that lasted a couple hours that was
completely disorganized that nobody
brought any weapons to and blah blah
blah blah blah they have to deal with
that then there's this history professor
he's freaking out about the
and he and i that he dares sit there
with his fake news man glasses and his
perfectly pressed shirt and jacket i do
my own by the way okay that's why my
collars are sometimes a little relaxed
but that's my vibe
but his are very perfect because he's
got 18 people in charge of his shirt and
his glasses and all that stuff
that he sits there and pretends that we
as journalists the time to be
non-partisan is over we're journalists
that we have to save the
republic it's so bananas it's just so
ridiculous it's and nobody's buying it i
know no one's buying it but the reason i
wanted to show you that clip is because
i think it gets to the heart of what
these people think that they are they
think oh perhaps there was a time when
we could have been honest it's just so
odd that he's saying it out loud maybe
there was a time where we could be
honest maybe there was a time where we
could debate things but now there's so
many nazis over there there's the
january 6th thing there's a history
professor over there we've got to do
something to save the republic it's
complete drivel drivel nonsense complete
rule of nonsense oh and speaking of
drivel nonsense
arguably my greatest segue ever here's
the view
and there are trump donors who are now
giving to desantis meaning they're
giving to his quote re-election campaign
right for governor but they know he's
raising much more money than he's
actually going to need for the
governor's race and as a result he's
going to have this huge war chest at the
end of this re-election campaign guess
where that's going to go you were saying
he's got about 200 million he's going to
have about 200 million probably by the
time of the election he's got 125 people
giving money to these people well and by
the way sunday made a good point for
folks who aren't familiar what a lot of
these these apps and websites do is you
click to give once and it actually signs
you up to recurringly give it is so
unfair it is a grift people are losing
their homes it's their little surprise
there's a great thing
so a lot of the people are giving it
lord okay
do we have to do desantis 101 he kept
the state open
florida is thriving he is defending free
speech he is stopping the ever
encroaching federal government he's
making sure we don't get flooded with
illegals he is doing all of the right
things like if you got a checklist the
right things bam he's just checking them
off every day that guy goes to to bed
and puts his head on the pillow knowing
that he did good work on any given day
and i i'm telling you i'm meeting so
many people here of every walk of life
that are so appreciative of desantis and
being in florida and doing it right so
they're upset that he's raising money
now why is he raising money now first
off he doesn't need 200 million dollars
to to win his re-election here obviously
he's running against this guy charlie
chris charlie crist used to be governor
of florida he was a republican governor
of florida years ago now he's a democrat
he's also a closet case people used to
talk about that but now i guess they
don't talk about it anymore he has
absolutely no support he's an
inauthentic
weirdo he's just there's nothing there
so desantis obviously is going to crush
it and i would say in many ways desantis
already is the president of the united
states in a certain regard he's not
president by title but he's president in
terms of the president is supposed to be
the leader of the country and if america
is still a free nation that is ruled by
law and the founding documents and all
those things then ron desantis basically
is the president already
but they're so obsessed with this guy
because the meme has gone out to the
media right now it's very obvious what
has happened there was an article in the
new yorker that basically was saying uh
it's by this guy jonathan chait another
one of these kind of trump deranged
people who gets everything wrong but you
know in lefty world you always move up
uh how ron desantis is actually worse
than trump because he's got all the
policies of trump but he's competent so
it's like competent hitler the other one
we had was stupid hitler now we got
competent hitler that is going to be the
meme on desantis for sure oh my god he
staffs right he knows what battles to
fight to fight he doesn't have the
personal baggage and all that stuff so
he's got all the good trump stuff and
he's functional oh dear lord what are we
going to do
but what's interesting about that video
of those ladies on the view
is that that girl
that's sitting on the right over there
alyssa farah she was in the trump
administration okay so she was in the
trump administration but now she is
making a career going after trump going
after republicans she's the perfect pet
republican right these people that go on
msnbc they go on the view they get pat
on the head they get a cookie and they
have no shame and she dare calls ron
desantis a grifter the people that are
giving ron desantis money are they're
giving him money because they actually
it's money well spent it's a rare moment
where actually giving money to a
politician is money well spent because
you are helping someone strengthen their
ability to defend you not rule over you
it is a distinction that is lost on
these clown people but anyway this alice
alissa farrow who is now becoming a
media darling she's on cnn and she's on
the view and she throws all of her
former colleagues under the bus and she
pretends she has nothing to do with
trump and all of those things well she's
getting a sort of nice moment with the
mainstream media but
she doesn't realize that they are going
to destroy her too and sonny's sort of
trying to tell her i'm very curious as
to alyssa's opinion on this because she
probably knows bannon and all the other
crazy people she used to work with so
i'm very curious as to what you think
deal with the devil lady that's what you
signed you signed a deal with the devil
they will keep you around while you are
useful and the second they are done with
you oh you were a trump person you
ushered all this in blah blah blah so
good luck on your little contract for
the next year or so but this will not
end well for you alyssa farah but if you
want to do the show and talk about it
i'm all ears but let's contrast the
craziness of the view and these people
who are very upset that there are people
who actually care about freedom and
liberty in this country with people who
actually do care about freedom and
liberty in this country here's ron
desantis some of the people in
washington like can we actually agree
that women get pregnant and not men
because
because they don't seem to say that
i mean it's just it's just unbelievable
some of the stuff that you're hearing
about that
not to be a dick but women can get
pregnant and men can't see what i did
there not to be a dick
um yeah it's true and that is a uh a
statement that say i don't know four
years ago would not have been
controversial imagine here's i was
thinking about this this weekend
actually um imagine just picture your
grandma picture your grandma and grandpa
on either side can you guys do it with
me in this room let's all picture our
grandparents now picture your
grandparents at say 30 years old and
imagine them being told at say 30 years
old that men can get pregnant
how do you think grandma would have
reacted back then how do you think
grandpa would react do you see this is
what the destruction of logic and
reality and everything else they would
have known it was [ __ ] they would
have gone to europe and fought a war
over it oh you telling me that dudes can
get pregnant we're going to normandy you
understand that's what they would have
done instead we sit here and take it
from these genderless queer whack jobs
that's what we do but we are fighting
back ron desantis is fighting back
that's why things are going so well here
and it's not just that he's fighting
back just against against the assault on
on biology uh he's also fighting back on
this lunacy being taught to our kids in
school i think parents in this country
should be able to have their kids go to
school watch cartoons just be kids
without having an agenda shoved down
their throat every minute
again just basic basic truth but you can
see it can't you see what the media is
going to do they're going to take all of
those things they're going to say he's
using that coded language of the culture
wars just like donald trump but he knows
what he's doing trump was an idiot trump
was orange and had crazy hair and was
tweeting all day long this guy might get
stuff done he's ten times worse than
trump
ridiculous nonsense i feel good about
this monday show for the record
uh what did you say phoenix you said a
9-1 today
eight nine from michael what did you say
you're moving it to nine five you can't
move post show you can't move in the
middle of the show what did you say you
said eight what
you said eight
which makes no sense i was feeling good
on a monday rested and refreshed phoenix
congratulations you're getting
a cookie something uh yeah big show
today big show okay uh we got a meme
monday for you over at the room court
locals community i really like this one
look at this if the titanic sunk in 2022
sorry sir women and children first i'm
trans just perfect i'm probably getting
booted from twitter for that one i had a
good run it's okay a couple comments
from the locals community and then we
got a great cold clothes for you jumping
jeff
says trudeau has put up a canadian iron
curtain he has you know the iron curtain
of course which most people associate
with the soviet union
in the 80s the idea that you could not
get out basically if you were a
dissident uh if you were against the
regime et cetera et cetera in essence
there is a version of that in canada
right now i think still on planes you
can't get on and leave is that right i'm
pretty sure yeah that you cannot if you
are not
vaccinated you cannot get on a plane and
leave canada right now that is a type of
iron curtain i mean it's just evil he is
he is right there i mean the two guys
that i think you have to watch out for
most in the west right now it's newsom
and justin trudeau it's like they were
separated by birth like the devil's wife
had twins and she sent one to canada and
one to california and they're slimy
smarmy liars
soulless that's the word that's they are
just gavin newsom is soulless
tallway says not just a mask mandate but
an indoor mask mandate just when you
think insanity can't possibly get worse
i mean look they're just gonna mask
these idiots up again and they're gonna
want it i think it's one of the reasons
that you must believe in something else
besides politics otherwise every study
and every uh every edict that these
people put on you you will think that
they somehow have a right to tell you
what to wear on your face and what to
inject yourself with and a whole bunch
more and by the way the woman who's in
charge we should have had a picture of
her i don't think we can get at this
point this woman barbara ferrer i think
that's her name
uh this woman looks like skeletor we'll
show a picture of her tomorrow
they're taking health advice from a
woman who looks like skeletor these
people take health advice from jerry
nadler who looks like the penguin from
batman they take health advice from
rachel levine i'll just leave it at that
i mean these people are completely
insane and no one has a right to tell
you what to put on your face or what to
inject yourself with but enjoy it la
enjoy it i'm never going back nuclear
patrick says look at the light
reflecting off gavin's greasy head he is
a greasy slimy
rat
i don't like him
if you'd like to play along and comment
during the show you can go to rubin
report.locals.com the full interview
with patrick bett david who's just a
great thinker and and businessman and
gets what freedom's all about great
story immigrant from iran really great
uh fully enjoyed it uh is all across
platforms right now and
finally
we leave you with the elderly man
pretending to be the president of the
united states
have a nice day
[Music]
you